okay okay metroid prime federation force
wow we didn't even plan that that's I
saw it coming okay yeah I mean it's the
name of the game it's a it's like that's
the title of the game and it sat on 3ds
is the review up yet Peter the review
and progress is up literally just got
the last few edits for the full review
so that'll be live in like an hour okay
I mean it's it's coming hot on the heels
of this yeah can you reveal the score
before it goes is this like a preview of
them well if you go to Google right now
for some reason if you type in Metroid
Prime Federation for us it says that
case was he's giving it one out of ten
holy [ __ ] you're giving this a one edit
and it's probably some sort of algorithm
disaster that's at that something would
that happen like a week or two ago or
another game or like he hadn't given it
a score or there was like a different
score that appeared there I do not
believe that that is not anything that
we're involved in yeah that is just all
Google pulling something that's a stop
being weird google and so does i mean
it's not getting it whatever then it's
not getting one attend I don't want to
talk about the score okay on this um i
would rather actually focus on just the
game just talking about the game can we
talk about it then the first thing i
want to talk about then is the the
quandary you had last week when i last
talked to you about it which is this as
a game which has quite a steep or no it
has a difficulty curve that seems to be
pretty I don't know like it's it's
almost wanting you to play with more
people because this is a multiplayer
game right it is both a single player in
a multiplayer game okay and I will
defend that position despite people's
cried to the contrary who sorry cuz on
the main menu it says solo play it says
play with others or whatever like co-op
those are two separate things the game
makes it clear that you can do one or
the other it even gives you an item to
boost your you know your strengths yeah
like how much damage you've given and
how little you take and so it's the
game's thing you can play this by
yourself the problem is the difficulty
so let's say the hip points of the
enemies or the damage they deal does not
change depending on your party size
right whether you are playing with four
people or by yourself you are facing
these same odds now granted
single-player you get that item but that
item doesn't allow you to be in more
than
place at a time right yeah and then a
game like this where it's so punishing
when you die you have to start a mission
completely over mmm playing with other
people that can revive you in a matter
of so yeah that's what I'm tapping the
button changes the game entirely you can
just play with reckless abandon and die
and get revived single player you screw
up for like two seconds on a boss with a
one hit kill thanks for trying and got a
lot of missions that are like keep this
thing protected keep this thing alive
and you're just low escort missions yeah
so to be fair Peter was playing the
review he didn't get through to he got
hit a wall at a boss right yeah and so
it was like he Justin can you help me
out can you start playing this so I was
like all right I'm gonna play it got
through the first two missions by myself
I'm like Peter kind of sucks in this
game it's not hard at all yeah I this is
actually kind of fun that a playthrough
I get to the boss because to play
together you have to both have unlocked
that level I can't just join me like all
play this with you see what's out of
grinds to get to the level where is okay
right it's like this is no problem then
I get to the bottom line you know I'll
just try it out it's fine totally kills
me like it one hit kills like this boss
and when you die how long is the fight
if it can one hit kill you was like a
two-stage fight brighton so the first
stage takes maybe 10 minutes oh my god
right okay so yeah and then you get to
the second stage and maybe you last
another minute but the moments boss says
this one move if you're in the wrong
place and you can't turn around very
quickly so you can lose track of the
bosses he goes underwater right and
you're like on a little island in the
middle of a body of water so or if he
throws you off the island you lose so so
I guess when you're together did you
beat this boss Oh as soon as soon as we
teamed up like looking at five minutes I
think we just totally trounced it was no
problem at all and was the next level as
difficult or was this like a weird
isolated got to mishit that was mission
7 I think we got to mission 13 or 14 and
then we faced a boss that we couldn't
fin it we couldn't beat we played it for
maybe 15 minutes and there was like a
20-minute session we just couldn't do it
and I flipped my lid I was a [ __ ] but I
like punch myself in the leg and like
yelled in the office like [ __ ] this I'm
done but uh Peter hurts himself yeah
then over the weekend the servers were
alive okay and I was able to go online
and play with a full party we're randoms
p brand understand in four minutes and
48 seconds we beat the boss that me and
Justin could not beat in 20 minutes
right and it only took that long because
you literally have to deal with like a
mechanism you have to
reload there was no faltering we were
just back and forth back and forth doing
it that's exactly how long it should
take right if you're at your best that's
not so then they're basically like the
game is clearly meant to be played with
lots of people but it's being sold as a
game where you can play this is meant to
be played as a pool party because it's
too easy at that point right okay yeah
like there's no challenge and when
there's no challenge you're kind of just
going through the motions right you have
this ability to choose weapons before
you go into battle hmm uh you might
think okay I'll be a healer I'll be this
in that with a full party you don't need
that sort of system right everyone just
shoots anything they want if they fall
okay someone goes by and tap the button
and they get revived yeah that gets nice
to kill somebody but it's it feels
unnecessary when you're with a full
party where is when you're on your own
or with two people it sounds like the
most incredibly difficult like like my
new show you're like working that like
yes yeah you're struggling and like it's
okay there's there's a there's a way to
strike a balance there and that is to
figure out the ideal party size for each
mission like Justin was saying a lot of
the earlier ones and some of the fillers
between bosses can be handled on your
own and are okay like the challenge is
there because you're keeping up with a
lot of enemies by yourself there's a lot
of pressure and your there's a lot of
action going on but then you know you
have too many people and maybe you the
mission isn't doesn't feel like that
right oh that's so strange the chat kind
of losing her mind about it baking pan
is saying this sounds like atrocious
game design holy cow as soon saying it
does not seem to adapt well based on You
Man two players it does not adapt at all
yeah it doesn't even try it is yeah and
it is yeah I think it's surprising how
well it does the controls for our first
person here cuz I thought that was going
to be the worst part like the first
person game on your 3ds and it's dumb
how slow you move how you not having the
ability just do a quick turn to look
behind you but the controls were
actually shooting and getting around
like that worked really well it works
really well i mean the left analog stick
controls your forward and reverse
movement and your rotation left and
right hmm so you can move and look to
your side and then when we want to look
up or down hold down the art button and
use the gyroscope in the system alright
the system and it works really really
well like as he said that is one of the
best things about the game is that it
proves that like you can have a great
first person shooter on 3d yes hmm it's
just a shame that this game doesn't
deliver and you sort
adventure that lives up to metroid prime
which it pulls from and like just
because it's not really a metroid game
that doesn't make it bad to begin with
yeah it just means in a way it doesn't
have a crutch right and it should be
uneven footing just on its own terms but
it it can't succeed on its own terms
regardless of whether samus is in it or
what role she plays all right any of
that so yeah so people who are going to
be fans of the series are not quite
getting what they want because they you
know they want a traditional Metroid
game and they want Sam is there to be a
part of it yeah it doesn't feel like it
expands out on that the Metroid lure in
a fun way and just as a general shooter
like it just doesn't live up to your
expectations of like I just want a fun
shooter yeah it's really stupid like the
missions they say okay click down on the
box it's really stupid we need you to do
after this mission to accomplish a thing
that's gonna throw the Pirates and you
go and do it and they're like cool next
mission it's like remember that thing
you did didn't really work we're the
worst marine semper the last two
missions before the final boss they say
okay we found this energy transfer link
where they're sending energy from one
planet to another no we destroy this
will destroy their base that's causing
us all our problems right and we'll be
fine destroy the oil pipeline got it
right you literally destroy it and it's
like turns out they have another one you
have to go do the exact same thing in a
different location like this is the this
is the final act of the game you're
bringing me through to the end and
that's all you have and you're the space
marine so the thing is like you're the
Marines but all the time you're like we
found reports of Samus Aran a bounty
hunter who's found giving us new
information like aren't you the Marines
shouldn't you be like more put together
than this give a whole army was just for
do do you guys go out there Samus did a
little bit better trying to do what she
did god that's weird it's almost like it
sounds like teasing the fact that you're
not being like it seems like in a way
better job than you are yeah you kind of
suck guys I guess the last question on
this is when so presumably you got to
the end with playing with Justin yeah no
you didn't Justin couldn't do it
together awesome when you went online
had you had to play the party for so
could you go back and play those in solo
when you unlock on one tier do you
unlock on the other or when you were
there's no tier its just oh it's just
your any together I know what you do
unlock is hard mode
I don't do that this that's like okay
good wats does that make okay there's
not make it so that the early levels are
fun now when you're on your own I don't
care I don't want to replay them they
are so they're so basic they're so basic
I mean look if you're going to implement
a hard mode yeah how difficult is it to
just make that the four player mode did
I mention there's a soccer game no oh
yes I miss are you like rocket league i
sure do we'd love rocket League also
this your ball tell me about soccer game
okay it's basically Lucille Ball okay
but on a 3ds and so is you have this big
ball everyone's trying to get in goal
because everyone can shoot at it from as
far away as they want to everyone is
shooting at it no matter where they are
in the ball just like like moves inches
like everyone's got like like did
dhalsim legs so they're just kicking
this bowl consulate is the least it is
oh god oh my god all right they put
energy into that but not you can
download that your frame yeah barely can
download it for me I sure this isn't
getting one at a time his love you
upstairs it controls really well they're
some of the boss fights when you have as
a teen that's the right size i did play
a few missions like three people yeah
the game felt more balanced okay cool
but i but that doesn't take away from
the fact that the game forces you to put
in the lake work to figure out like what
the difficulty should be and how to make
it happen yeah that's not the way this
is supposed to work yeah that seems kind
of strange yes they go I drew a prime
Federation force you are so uncertain to
that name I know I do you know why okay
there's another game but it but I
actually got a rose freedom for ya
Irrational Games made this yeah so this
is ken Levine's Metroid game review up
soon on gay.com go check it out